bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj oggi siamo su
john the grudge secondo episodio
eravamo rimasti che praticamente
nell'ultimo episodio era morto fufi
morto buffi perché praticamente è uscito
da solo dall'ascensore vabbè è morto è
praticamente sto gioco si divide in
episodi quindi da quando è morto fufi
nella fabbrica nella fabbrica
abbandonata abbiamo sbloccato un nuovo
episodio che el ospedale abbandonato
giustamente e quindi niente praticamente
adesso andiamo a fare l'ospedale
abbandonato che dal nome promette
benissimo anzi peggio della fabbrica
perché la fabbrica ok ci stiamo
ci stiamo svegliando perfetto
sento anche dei passi cominciamo
benissimo
si ok c'è qualcuno che sta correndo
fuori non so se stanno facendo le corse
clandestine
ok c'è una bella foto con i volti
oscurati perfetto
ebbene ci stiamo alzando fantastico
adesso come al solito non sappiamo come
siamo finiti qui probabilmente
la sera prima abbiamo bevuto litri e
litri di vodka è
e alcolici a tutto andare che cazzo è
successo
si è spenta la luce abbiamo tirato fuori
la torcia fantastico no il bello che
come ho tirato da fuori la torcia si è
spenta la luce in automatico cioè lui lo
sapeva
cos'è questo rumore perché nessuno
risponde
deve esserci qualche ragazzino che si
diverte qui in giro si correva per i
corridoi e vabbè ma cosa fanno le
infermiere e spero li facciano uno
sgambetto nichi o stavolta penso che di
essere un maschio non so se mi chi è un
nome da maschio per ora vero che causerà
astronomo che cazzo rumore mi son cagato
addosso perché ho puntato la torcia ed è
spuntata l'ombra li ho detto mica sta
spuntando qualcuno c'è neanche siamo
partiti mi son mi sono già preso male
vabbè comunque ho notato che nell'ultimo
episodio raga dicevo non so se mi
vengono spontanee dire troppe parolacce
quando succedono cose inaspettate e
tenterò di contenermi
porca [ __ ] non vedo niente allora
aspettate un attimo qui non c'è niente
fortunatamente ok non posso aprire nulla
e vabbè allora dobbiamo soltanto uscire
qua credo aprì la porta va a rispondere
al telefono
ok ok ok no no no no ok ok partenza
buona
ok il cazzo buona vabbè mi devo
contenere mi contengo mi contengo
scusate scusate bene
sì non si corre nei corridoi non si
corre dov'è andato si è ficcato sei qui
sotto no il bello è che qua la gente nel
film horror si corre verso i muri e
quando si corre verso i muri si scompare
tipo appunto harry potter
allora se riesco ad andare a rispondere
al telefono sono talmente impedito che
minchia è sta roba è una torcia la
torcia più potente batteria di riserva è
praticamente lai smontata perfetto se
riesco a girarmi sono così impedito che
non riesco a girarmi perfetto
devo andare a rispondere al telefono che
asm e chi era chi è la non fate scherzi
ha smesso di squillare il telefono
perfetto ebbene ha smesso di squillare
il telefono l'abbiamo fatto in tempo a
rispondere è vabbè andiamo di qua
apriamo una porta a casa ok ok ok
perfetto perfetto perfetto dai
tranquilli tranquilli tranquilli non so
perché la visuale fa così schifo non
riescono anche a girarmi però vabbè c'è
una tenda ci sono che cos'è sta roba
questa è uguale la mia sedia a far data
è roba va bene non importa dettagli
dettagli dettagli
ok
devo devo tirare la tenda devo tirarla a
te non voglio tirarla tenda perfetto non
c'è nessuno mi aspetto veramente mi
aspettavo di tutto ma non c'è nessuno
allora devo ma c'è un'altra porta qui
non l'avevo mica vista e non possa
legare un attimo su facebook per
controllare notifica
presumo di no ok allora usciamo non
serve a niente sostanza una roba inutile
ok usciamo sciamu sciamu sciamu perfetto
qua dovremmo rientrare nel corridoio se
tutto va bene
e vabbè prima ok si è scassata la
maniglia cosa benissimo benissimo
benissimo benissimo
ok allora qua non so che cosa devo fare
raga io sto andando a caso per i
corridoi senza una meta perché non ho
idea di dove devo andare
presumo che debba tentare di uscire a
sto punto perché veramente non ha idea
di cosa fare però in line tanto vedo una
torcia ok ed è già qualcosa questo è il
bagno delle signore io non so neanche se
sono maschio femmina però non importa
andiamo avanti lo stesso torcia torcia
due torce vai con due ok batteria di
riserva ma l'altra l'ho persa cioè mi si
è smaterializzata l'altra batteria
dettagli lasciamo perdere
non so che cosa devo fare ragazzi non ho
idea di dove devo andare io vado nel
bagno delle donne così scopro se sono
maschi o femmine non si vede neanche
attraverso lo specchio
quindi niente
cosa devo fare qualcosa cosa devo fare
no no no no no no mi vogliono aprire
quella maledetta no vai via vai via vai
di merda no no no no no no no no no
cazzo cazzo
ok no no no no no no non ti faccio
niente io io sono qui di passaggio mi
sono svegliato nel letto non c'entro
niente c'entra niente perché va bene è
sparita avuto avuto tanta tanta pietà
grazie grazie mille
bene al suo punto vado a controllare se
ha fatto i bisogni nel bagno no
veramente non c'è niente c'è la carta
igienica pro può servirmi no devo per
forza aprire tutte le porte si perché
evidentemente ci può essere qualcosa che
mi serve tipo batterie che vanno via
facilmente no qua ci sono due carte
igieniche va beh niente da fare ragazzi
non serviva a niente sostanza solo
incontrare nella nostra amica bene
usciamo sciamu sciamu sciamu di qua
perché già l'odio sto posto via peggio
dell'altro sta roba che cos'è un
distributore di preservativi è suonata
la campanella l'intervallo cosa
ok ha smesso fortunatamente non idea di
che cosa fosse ma tentiamo di entrare
qui dentro che è chiuso perfetto darà
niente
l'ultima porta noi l'ascensore
l'ascensore io non ci andrei però
evidentemente per uscire dal suo posto
l'unico
non funziona maledizione ok dobbiamo
trovare un altro ci saranno delle
maledette scale per scendere sempre
ammesso che siamo al piano superiore
magari siamo al piano terra non lo so so
che non succederà niente di buono se
finirà le batterie questo è sicuro
però non voglio finirle si apre st porta
si sia apre si apre tranquilli
tranquilli
no non c'è nessuno perfetto
ci sono dei letti ok che cazzo cos'è la
sto verso va beh noi usciamo non
interessano meter usciamo tanto non
serve a niente
via via via via via via via di qua via
di qua via
usciamo usciamo fuori fuori da qui
assolutamente ok bene non è ancora
successo niente mentre apriva le porte
fortunatamente qua ci sono già stato no
questo è il bagno degli uomini perfetto
dato che non si continua a non capire se
sono maschi e una femmina entriamo anche
qui dentro c'è c'è della roba che schifo
è ma che schifo
devo devo aprirla no non si apre bene
non si sa non si apre ragazzi non si
apre e torno volentieri indietro
diamo via andiamo via di qui che tanto
non si apre la porta quindi non serve a
niente
non è che uscito o no no va bene così va
bene così non so che cos'era
non so se hai mangiato spaghetti e gli
hai ributtati fuori neri però non mi
interessa saperlo
ok ragazzi amo andandola d'altra parte
del dell'ospedale dalla parte opposta
costanza 303 sostanza 300 39 ancora
aperta no perfetto proviamo la prima che
questa prima di arrivare alla fine
ok ok niente perfetto vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai ok letto ok cazzo era però
scaffale detto sgabello dillo che stai
complottando tutto dillo ti tengo
d'occhio se provi a muoverti ancora una
volta sono cazzi tua ok
perfetto ok raga andiamo abbiamo finito
per la mente tutte le stanze dobbiamo
soltanto uscire di qua e andare a destra
e dovrebbe esser cibo le scale penso
anche perché abbiamo finito tutto ok
bene andiamo solo più a destra e ci
dovremmo essere
c'è il telefono che squilla di nuovo no
mi sembrava che squillasse il telefono
bene allora usciamo di qua usciamo
bibite allora vediamo subito se c'è la
fanta perché se c'è la fanta io c'ho
anche 7 quindi volentieri allora abbiamo
detto reid
perfetto allora andiamocene via perché
tanto non serve a niente
ehi voi qualcosa c'è la roba delle
bibite vuoi ti prendo una coca dove vai
guarda che offro io è mica devi pagare
tu ne sei andato ok
vabbè non vuole essere gentile offrirle
cose gli altri se ne vanno ma io ormai
raga el'abi turno tanto non c'è niente
cioè praticamente finora abbiamo aperto
porte non c'era nulla quindi tranquilli
ok questa non l'avevo già vista prima a
noi benissimo ragazzi tornino non voglio
andare avanti ti prego ok le ciabatte
metti tele perché sono molto carina anzi
metti teletu che corrida un'ora che
scalzo come un maniaco
mettiti ste ciabatte fammi il favore
dato che non sarebbe se nessuno mette
delle tuffa misto favore non c'è
perfetto non c'è neanche qui la bora che
abbiamo aperto 250 porte non c'era nulla
quindi tranquilli
ok raga allora c'è un'altra torcia e ci
sono degli altri spaghetti non penso
siano capelli
credo ok io non aprirò quella porta però
c'è una torcia ragazzi sto finendo le
batterie molto ma molto rapidamente non
devono scendere a zero non devono
assolutamente scendere a 0 io intanto in
quella porta non c entra in questa
ragazza non le ultime due porte poi
abbiamo visto praticamente ogni ogni
stanza l'abbiamo vista sono le ultime
due porte quindi controlliamo solo più
queste poi dovremmo aver finito
ok perfetto questa molto tranquilli ok
ok csaba perfe guarda perché non si
mette le ciabatte quel bambino malato
che corre da un'ora scalzo per i
corridoi ci sono ciabatte sparse ovunque
di nessuno ma perché non se le mette
vabbè qua c'è una stanza ok perfetto la
tenda non la posso tirare sila posso
tirare usciamo di qua raga siamo
costretti ad entrare nell'ultima porta
ma che cazzo ma
sei stato tu lo sgabello di merda vero
sei ancora stai ancora complottando
allora io ti giuro che la prossima volta
mi fai uno scherzo ti prendo a calci
allora io da adesso in avanti dichiaro
guerra tutti gli sgabelli siete contro
di me va bene usciamo di qua perché già
mi son rotto di stare qui dentro
ok ragazza la dobbiamo andare ad aprire
l'ultima porta quella che quella che ci
troviamo davanti ad esso
dopodiché ho finito tutte le porte e
quindi quello per quella penso sia la
porta finale anche perché se continuiamo
così
ok la 305 da 305 l'ultima porta
andiamo sotto un'occhiata rapida al
corridoio per controllare che non sia
saltato tutto in aria perfetto spero di
finirlo in fretta perché le batterie
stanno morendo pian piano ok ok calmi
molto calmi
ok perfetto libera libera libera libera
anche questa tutte uguali sostanze sono
tutte identiche allora chi è che ha
mangiato gli spaghetti l'ultima porta
ok merda merda o cazzo zeri raga dying
bene
ok perfetto
the ring anche in the grudge perfetto no
perché l'ho riacceso
vabbè noi continuiamo c'è sono state
ndaq e devo tirare se ci trova lo
sgabello stavolta ti tira un calcio male
the ok si spende ma si spegne da sola
sarò da non capito va beh non mi
interessa
usciamo di qua perché già lo detesto sto
posto e abbiamo finito tutte le porte
allora se mi hai rotto le palle hai
rotto le palle
la devi smettere comunque cos'è che è
successo 6 gallo
è
perché c'è perché partita musica ragazzi
è partita la musica a caso va beh
usciamo abbiamo finito tutte le porte
non so dove andare ho finito il ragazzo
deve andare ma marche cass
cos'è sta roba me lo spiegate voi è
apparsa della roba a terra non so cosa è
bene e cosa mi rappresenta
non lo so però devo fare raga la
batteria maledizione allora devo pregare
che funzioni
adesso cazzo la batteria da batteria
no no no no no no
che è successo no no no no no e quindi
non vedo niente adesso mica un casino
[Musica]
un calcio alla scrivania ad ogni suo
fatto malissimo maledizione
sicuramente se un fifone ammazzati
ammazzati riprova birr ag ha allora
facciamo così
chiudo all'episodio qua dato è comunque
penso che l'episodio non fosse alla fine
in generale se fosse riuscito a capire
cosa fare nel prossimo episodio partirò
direttamente dalla fine
quindi dal punto dove ci eravamo fermati
per vedere che cosa c'era dopo e poi
niente farò anche quello successivo
ovviamente perché dato che mancava
pochissimo praticamente per finirlo
quasi sicuramente per rimettere prossimo
episodio vedrete la prossima mappa che
non ho idea di quale sia
va beh come al solito servito vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che trovate
come sempre nella descrizione fatelo
anche per la mia gamba che sta
implorando pietà tirato un calcio
assurda scrivania e vabbè se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e ci vediamo
il prossimo video bella ragazza